everybody
in this replica of a Roman Theater in
the city of suleimania Melodies echo
through the night
Regional music festival in Iraq's
semi-autonomous Kurdish region to
promote peace
participants hope this message can
inspire people across the Middle East
we accept and embrace different cultures
and races and we say that through
traditional art I think the most
important messages we can convey is
through music
Iraqi singers who have been around for a
long time say
the festival is a good way to celebrate
traditional music
[Music]
unfortunately our modern songs are
plagued with shallowness so the
festival's an opportunity for the
participant countries to revive their
Rich traditional music
[Music]
award-winning soprano provincial car
performs in kormanji one of the Kurdish
languages spoken in Southeastern turkey
she says she sings for peace through the
musical Heritage of her Homeland all
things that will we will love Love
Freedom you know peace so we really we
need we need this because in Middle East
of course we need this
Slovenia is the epicenter of culture and
art in Iraq's Northern Kurdish region
we've had a lot of different talents
over the years and way way back we have
always been interested in Arts and Music
so I think it's bringing back the past
in a way that the youth can enjoy it
people here are proud that some of these
Arabic and Kurdish folklore Melodies and
instruments have become part of western
music
Festival comes at a crucial time
Regional Kurdish Administration has been
mired in a political and economic
dispute with the central government in
Baghdad but many here believe that music
can bridge the gap
between communities and create a Common
Language to address issues that affect
everyone
organizers want to make the festival an
annual event to reflect the Region's
diverse history and culture of
civilization that dates back thousands
of years
they hope these Melodies can Empower
them to inspire peace in their troubled
region
Al
suleimania Northern Iraq
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera